Sweaty palms, short breaths, feeling uncomfortable?
Do you have your smart phone on you?
Do I?
Hey, Julia here for Dnews
Can’t function without your phone?
Panic when you can’t find it?
New research says you’re not alone.
Researchers from the University of Missouri
sought to study this stressful situation.
They found that just being away from your
phone can cause anxiety and make you perform
worse on important tasks.
To figure out what happens when people are
separated from their phones, the researchers
put people to task filling out a simple word
search puzzle, while hooked up to a blood
pressure cuff.
The researchers told the participants the
experiment was to test new pressure cuffs,
so they wouldn’t suspect it was really about
their phones.
While they puzzled away, the researchers asked
them to rate how they were feeling, what their
level of anxiety was and if they had any feelings
of pleasantness or unpleasantness.
After the first word search puzzle was complete,
researchers told the participants that their
phones were causing bluetooth interference
with the blood pressure cuff and had to be
moved to the other side of the room.
Once separated from their phones, the participants
started on a second puzzle and in the middle
of figuring out the puzzle, researchers called
them.
Imagine, sitting in a strange room, with a
weird thing on your arm, you can’t figure
out where the word “Alaska” is in the
puzzle, and YOUR PHONE STARTS TO RING.
What if it’s your mom, what if Timmy fell
down a well again?
You just don’t know.
Not surprisingly, participants reported feeling
unpleasant and anxious, and their heart rates
and blood pressure increased.
But not only did they feel worse, but they
did worse on the crossword puzzle.
So what did the researchers conclude?
Phone anxiety is a very real thing and can
lead to physiological anxiety and poor cognitive
performance.
They suggest that phones have become such
a huge part of our lives that phones are now
an extension of our sense of self we feel
a loss of a part of ourselves when we are
separated.
It seems this affects a lot of us.
Some researchers called it NoMoPhobia, or
fear of being without your phone.
60% of responders to a recent survey said
they can’t go more than an hour without
checking their phones and 73% said they panicked
last time they thought they lost it.
So what would you rather go without than put
down your phone?
One study found that most people would give
up other comforts before their phones.
70% would rather give up alcohol, 63% would
go without chocolate and 33% would rather
not have sex for a week than go without their
phones for a week.
Another study found that 11% of americans
would rather leave home without PANTS than
without their phones.
What to do about it?
Please keep your pants on and put your phone
in your pocket or purse.
If you need to stay focused on a task like
a meeting at work or a big test, keep your
phone on you, but turn it to vibrate or silent
mode so you won’t have any distractions.
Are you as addicted to your phone as I am?
let us know in the comments below and keep
checking out DNews for more science news everyday